en fait on est allés souper avec
plusieurs de nos amis on fêtait deux
anniversaires et on a quitté le music a
fait vers 00h40 pour rentrer à la maison
en saluant donc nos amis peut-être pour
la dernière fois plusieurs d'entre eux
manquent à l'appel encore
oh
c'était c'était des bandas milieu puis
on part puis on nous dit on s'embrasse
comme comme d'habitude puis on sait
qu'on les reverra jamais
quand quand les policiers les parents
arrivent et puis qu'on demande est
d'amener des choses qui leur
appartenaient pour vérifier la des
stèles samedi en fin de journée j'ai vu
les parents de guy bolduc arrivée de
chicoutimi j'ai vu des choses pendant
ces journées là qui ont suivi quand on a
travaillé avec la sûreté du québec pour
leur donner un coup de main j'ai
vraiment compris que ce qui nous
arrivait ça n'avait pas de sens on
mesure pas l'ampleur de ce qui s'est
vraiment passé quand le pauvre véhicule
je pense que c'était beaucoup de
l'instinct de survie
la seule façon pour ne pas revivre la
peine qui à ce moment là a été long mais
on n'a pas beaucoup toucher à notre
propre peine encore on a pleuré nos amis
qu on les enterrait mais c'est tout si
on avait su le 16 juillet tout ce qui
nous attendait à tous les niveaux on
n'arrête jamais réussi à passer au
travers
c'est une bouchée à la fois et la
politique pour moi c'était la seule
façon de comprendre le système est de
pouvoir l'améliorer
c'est peut-être nf probablement mais je
crois fermement qu'il faut faire un
méchant ménages et qu'on adapte les
programmes puis qu'on réduise la
bureaucratie ça n'a plus de sens
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez que vous
vous souhaitez mais vous souhaitez aussi
à votre communauté
la paire va trouver la paix ce qui est
pas facile non les petits moments de
paix sont précieux